actor Jeremy Renner is sharing the first
photo of himself after he was seriously
injured in a snow plowing accident over
the weekend he wants everyone to know
he's okay Omar via Franca has the story
in a post to his fans and well-wishers
Tuesday Marvel star Jeremy Renner shared
a selfie from his hospital bed showing
just some of the bruises he suffered in
a snowplow accident near his home in
Nevada on New Year's Day and Runner
wrote I'm too messed up now to type but
I send love to you all we believe this
was a tragic accident the Washoe County
Sheriff says the actor was run over by
his snow cat a vehicle weighing more
than 14 thousand pounds and used to plow
snow Mr Renard's personal vehicle which
was being driven by a family member had
become snuck in the snow near his home
after successfully Towing his personal
vehicle from its stuck location Mr
Renner got out of his piston bully to
speak to his family member at this point
it is observed that the Piston bullish
started to roll he's referring to the
machine's rubber tracks Renner suffered
blunt chest trauma and Orthopedic
injuries according to his spokesman just
days before he posted videos of himself
on social media using plows to clear
paths around his home in Washoe County
and had been using them to clear the
roads for him and his neighbors renner's
family said the two-time oscar-nominated
actor remains in critical but stable
condition adding Jeremy is making
positive progress and in good spirits
for CBS mornings I'm Omar via Franca
oh my goodness thank goodness he's okay
wow I mean and I you know I know he's
he's grievously injured but he looks
pretty good in that looks good and happy
for that the fact that he's sending love
to the people that are sending love to
him is a good sign hopefully he'll
recover
assistant he's a superhero yeah you're
right about that I mean he's a superhero
so that's right he's an Avengers right